le sujet de ce débriefing laurel broten
agents britanniques avant de commencer
puis je demander officiellement que
monsieur cure spencer était derrière ce
but avec tous les autres salanquais
je vous demande pardon je n'ai rien dit
j'ai cru vous entendre parler de ce
qu'elle a dit voulez-vous rapaces et la
bande
je sais qu'elle ne respecte pas nous
rêvions
mais c'est notre meilleur spécialiste du
renseignement
il ya un agent double qui opèrent à
berlin si on ne trouve pas avant la
chute du mur
ça pourrait déclencher une troisième
guerre mondiale
et n'oubliez pas ne faites confiance à
personne
notre contact et david personnel est
venu à berlin je m'appelle david orr tir
page et à chaussures le temps nous est
compté
je suis le seul dans cette ville qui
peut aider
[Musique]
je n'ai absolument aucune confiance en
toi
vous m'avez envoyé dans un sacrée paire
d'yeux mais vous le saviez déjà j'en
suis sûr
[Musique]
à
je ne sais pas à qui tu as à faire
[Musique]
bien l'angle de tir
ça faisait pas partie du plan ça fait
partie du mien est ce que tu sais sur
cette femme qui me suit
c'est plutôt canon je suis un peu
vous n'avez pas bien contact avec
l'agent bonsoir attendre l'automne j'ai
choisi cette vie et ça finira par me
tuer mais pas aujourd'hui
[Musique]